تاريخيًا، لم تتخلف الولايات المتحدة أبدًا
عن سداد ديونها، لذا لا نعرف كيف سيكون الأمر لأن
هذا من المحتمل أن يتسبب في
أضرار اقتصادية كبيرة في الولايات المتحدة وفي
جميع أنحاء العالم. أه تنضم إلينا
كريستي رومان، كبيرة مراسلي الأعمال في CNN،
من نيويورك للإجابة على هذا
السؤال الضخم  ماذا يحدث إذا
نفدت أموال أمريكا؟
لا، سوق السندات الحكومية الأمريكية هو
في الواقع حجر الزاوية في
النظام المالي العالمي. بصراحة تامة، لذلك نحن
لا نعرف حقًا ما هي
تأثيرات الريبل، نحن نعلم فقط أن
هرمجدون الكارثية هي تلك
الأنواع  من الكلمات التي يستخدمها الاقتصاديون وصانعو
السياسات عندما يتخيلون
عالمًا لا تملك فيه الولايات المتحدة ما
يكفي من المال لسداد كل أه
كل ديونها هناك حوالي 57
مليار دولار في
الحساب البنكي الآن خزائن الخزانة
صحيح  الآن ومع دخول شهر يونيو،
ستكون هناك بعض المدفوعات الكبيرة التي
ستكون ضرورية لاستحقاقات المحاربين القدامى
والضمان الاجتماعي التي يتم دفعها في
الأربعاء الثالث والرابع من
الشهر والسؤال الكبير هو ماذا
يحدث لوزارة الخزانة عندما
يقومون بذلك.  أنت تحاول تحديد الفواتير التي يجب
دفعها إذا لم تقم برفع حد الدين
كنوع من "ألعاب الجوع" التي تحاول
تحديد ما سيكون له
أقل قدر من الضرر ومساعدة معظم
الناس ربما تقرر الخزانة
الاحتفاظ بها  جميع مدفوعاتها الثابتة، إذا كان
بإمكانها ذلك، فسوف تحاول الضمان الاجتماعي
دفع مزايا المحاربين القدامى التي ستحاول
دفعها ولكن ربما ستمنح
المقاولين هذا ما
يحاولون اللعب به هنا في محاولة لمعرفة
كيفية عمل ذلك  الآن، إذا أعطيت
المقاولين الفيدراليين جزءًا كبيرًا من
الاقتصاد الأمريكي، فأنت في
موقف قدر فيه الاقتصاديون في بنك جولدمان
ساكس أنه في اليوم
التالي لمراجعة هذه الحالة X،
يمكنك في الواقع إغلاق عُشر المشروع.
الاقتصاد الأمريكي يوقف كل
هذا النشاط الاقتصادي الذي من شأنه
بالتأكيد أن يسبب الركود وربما
يسبب كارثة في
أسواق الأسهم والسندات في جميع أنحاء العالم.